[Música]
y quiero preguntarles esta tarde si ya
se imaginaron cómo van a ser de ancianos
usted cada uno de ustedes
puede estar enfermo
dependiente de otra persona esperando
que le subsane todas las necesidades
básicas suyas
sola solo y triste
estará trabajando
estará disfrutando con amigos o bailando
hasta el último día de sus vidas como
quieren
sé que imaginarse esto asusta mucho y
genera una cantidad de emociones que no
sabemos ni dónde meter
nosotros pensábamos antes que a los 60
años ya estábamos alistando la maleta
para irnos para el otro lado cierto sin
embargo
vamos a vivir 90 años de vida
en las zonas azules del mundo del
mediterráneo la esperanza de vida espera
hacer 120 años
o sea que usted a los 50 tiene que estar
pensando cómo va a vivir los 40
restantes
la esperanza de vida en colombia de
acuerdo al último censo este 81.1 año
de vida para las mujeres y de 75.4 para
los hombres se espera que la esperanza
de vida saludable sean diez años menos
sea que los últimos años como complicado
los hombres se mueren primero
un hombre para estar vivo para sentirse
feliz necesita sentirse admirado
una mujer necesitada
el hombre es de la calle y cuando se
pensiona iba a la casa se desperfila no
sabe qué hacer además de que empieza a
estorbar en la casa cierra
es más cuando nosotros veíamos las
personas de 60 años que ya estaban la
abuela de 60 años le empezamos a regalar
vestidos cafés grises azules oscuros
como para que estén de luto antes de
morirse
en el censo en el último el censo nos
demostró que la población colombiana
está envejeciendo seriamente en el 2005
teníamos 28.7 personas mayores de 60
años por cada 100 menores de 15 y en el
18 tenemos 40.4 ya que la sociedad tiene
que prepararse porque estamos entrando
en longevidad
el 23 por ciento de los hogares
unipersonales femeninos que hay en
colombia pertenecen a mujeres de tercera
edad
los hombres viven solos en una etapa
económicamente productiva cuando
empiezan a sentirse viejos se van pon de
la hermana para donde los hijos pero no
se quedan solos
los fijos dentro de este proceso los
fijos que acompañamos del proceso de
envejecimiento de los papás estamos tan
preocupados que estamos equivocándonos
mucho
en el afán y en el susto de que papá o
mamá se fracturen y yo me encarte con
ellos empezamos a limitar les la vida
mamá no vaya a llamar a manos de su papá
no haga tal o cual cosa
haciendo que poco a poco cada vez que yo
le digo que el nuestra paz se
desvalorice te los huesos ustedes
mineralizan y llega la tan asustante
fractura es una parado
de dónde sale este ejercicio de viaja la
cédula yo soy docente universitaria
acompaño enfermeros en su proceso de
formación y estoy realmente cansada de
ver el ensañamiento terapéutico de que
le alargamos la vida a la gente tenga
conciencia o no tenga mente o no dándole
una vida de tristes
pero también tenemos gente que baila en
cali tenemos bailarines de salsa de 85
90 años y es muy inspirador para mí mi
mamá
mi mamá fue una mujer absolutamente
dependiente
y nunca salió de su casa sin su
después de que quedó viuda nosotros
decíamos entre los hermanos que vamos a
tener que alguno cargar con ella porque
no sabía vivir sola esta mujer descubre
el mundo se consigue un grupo de amigos
se da el permiso de vivir en este monte
a los 70 vivir sola ahora tiene 80 viaja
por donde le da la gana hace lo que
quiere si ella pudo todos podemos
este programa como lo des viajar los es
para las personas que se resisten a
caminar de forma fácil para entrar al
tercer acto de su vida esperando que les
pesa oler lo que no le ha dolido a dejar
de hacer las cosas que ama a esperar que
sus hijos lo entretengan
si usted es de los que se resiste usted
es de los míos
y para usted es de ese tipo de programa
los componentes que tiene tiene varios
elementos que son muy importantes
nosotros tenemos una jerarquía en la
vida abuelos papás hijos
el adulto debe ocupar su puesto en la
jerarquía hasta el último día de su vida
yo no sé a los hijos de donde se les
metió que se iban a convertir en los
papás de sus papás
nada más cerrado si usted quiere tener
alguien en la familia que envejezca
hasta los 90 montando bicicleta bailando
teniendo vida propia asegúrese de
respetar el puesto que él tiene es muy
curioso con los asistentes al
entrenamiento cuando les enseñamos a
pararse en la jerarquía entonces si su
hijo le dice mamá no haga tal cosa usted
le dice gracias por tu opinión
yo como adulta tomaré la decisión yo
como adulta seguiré decidiendo sobre mi
vida
sobre mis bienes sobre mi salud que me
puede equivocar si claro como adulta
también lo voy a resolver
es también muy importante el tener un
equilibrio entre el dar y el recibir
papá y mamá se la pasaron dando dando
dan
y en este momento los hijos de forma muy
atrevida esperan que sigan dando dando
dan dentro del programa cuando alguien
se da cuenta que tiene un hijo de 40
años al que mantiene todavía es
profesional y ni siquiera paga parte del
apartamento porque es que usted tiene
que aprender a respetar los espacios del
otro papá no tiene la obligación de
crearle los hijos
papá no tiene la obligación de hacerle
todos los mandados porque está
desocupado
este cuento entre el dar y el recibir
[Música]
él debe saber que tiene un valor
importante dentro de la familia y que no
tiene que andar comprando el amor de sus
hijos ni tiene que andar perdiendo
dignidad con tal de que sus hijos no se
le alejen porque este miedo profundo a
la soledad hace que diga así a una
cantidad de cosas que quisiera decir que
no
trabajamos mucho en soltar la
expectativa del cuidado pilar sordo dice
que somos la última generación que cuido
de forma directa a sus papás
si nosotros vamos a necesitar cuidado
nuestros hijos pagarán para que nos
cuiden pero la idea es soltar que usted
no va a necesitar cuidados y usted
decidir una vida autónoma libre
saludable usted no va a necesitar ningún
tipo de cuidado
adicionalmente
tiene que acordar que usted tiene que es
apegarse desapegarse de su familia de
sus hijos ellos tienen que hacer su vida
y está bien uno encuentra otras nuevas
formas de familia los amigos que
comparten con nosotros las aficiones
cosas que estudiamos tenemos que
aprender a decir está bien que el otro
esté allá y yo acá un adulto no puede
cifrar su vida y su felicidad en que su
hijo venga a darle una vueltita que los
hace un domingo a dar una vueltita
porque él no tiene vida propia
hay que gestionar las emociones sabemos
ya de acuerdo a muchas investigaciones
que las emociones producen enfermedades
otras porque las que aprendemos de
gestionar las emociones a espantar el
fantasma del cáncer
a trabajar con amigos
a replantear el tipo de amor que me
gusta recibir para que la diabetes no se
acerque o las enfermedades
osteomusculares no tengan que llegar por
la desvalorización que tengo
este es un proceso
que ha sido muy doloroso para muchas
personas nos reímos mucho pero también
es muy doloroso darse cuenta que tanto
he perdido que tanto terreno he perdido
que tanto yo en serio en mi casa mando
yo soy la muchacha el servicio pues de
la pensión que paga la luz simplemente
qué valor tengo yo dentro de mi casa qué
reconocimiento en serio tengo de mi casa
cuando hablamos de que los 16 años
nosotros teníamos todas las ilusiones
las ganas de aprender muchas cosas que
cosas se le quedaron en el tintero que
no ha hecho es tiempo de volver a
reconstruirse jonathan ross está
aprobado desde la biología que empezamos
a envejecer a los 26 años y la curva
empieza a bajar y entre 40 y 49 nos
preguntamos mucho de qué pasa con mi
vida y si lo que estoy sintiendo es
adecuado y si hacemos los ajustes
necesarios porque tenemos que hacer una
serie de ajustes podemos entrar al
tercer acto de nuestra vida de forma
autónoma libre independiente y levantar
la curva
la vida no decrece la vida se mueve en
curva como no lo invita el el autor
jonathan round
envejece mal el que tiene más recuerdos
que proyectos
y no importa el tamaño del proyecto
pueden ser project el proyecto de
cambiarle el color a la puerta de la
casa
jamás te puede durar un rato mientras
cotiza pinturas busca mezclas va por el
maestro y establece un proyecto
las personas que tienen proyectos
envejecen bien y es importante que los
tengan todo el tiempo
quiero tomarme una parte para hablarle a
los tipos que acompañan el proceso
a los hijos respeto con letras
mayúsculas y sostenidas
a los tipos respeto por ese hombre y esa
mujer
que los formaron los apoyaron durante
toda la vida muertas de los labios
cuando le quiera dar órdenes a su papá a
su mamá
no lo haga no lo intente
apoye lo que le regaló sin auditoría
saben que es regalos sin auditoría
resulta que a la gente le dan 100 pesos
y al otro día le están preguntando qué
hiciste con la plata esos son regalos
con auditoría o los aretes no te he
visto los aretes pues
no apoyen a mamá papá dentro de la
teoría sistémica por mamá viene el
dinero y por para para el éxito esto es
buen negocio para los discos apoyen la
papaya mamá pero no le digan
permítales ser como quieran ser ellos
permítanles ser hablamos en el programa
de la muerte muchas culturas no hablan
de la muerte porque creen que la llaman
pero necesitamos hablar de cuáles son
sus expectativas ante la muerte usted
qué decisiones quiere tomar en l a los
picos para que su hijo al final puede
hacerse respetar su voluntad y no tenga
que tomar decisiones hablamos de algo
que se llama un cuadre de caja con la
vida que no tiene nada que ver con el
dinero
pararse frente a las cosas que se supone
la vida me debe
y hacer un inventario de las que yo le
debo le debo haber tratado mejor a mi
mamá
debo haber mis discos me deben haber
hablado de tal o cual forma y quitarme
las culpas y quitarme las cargas porque
yo necesito alivianar la maleta
es súper importante que los hijos
acompañen y apoyen a sus papás
yo les puedo asegurar que van a tener a
papá ya mamá más sanos felices
independientes siendo felices por
cuentas de ellos y no teniendo que
depender de ustedes sin embargo no
quiere decir que no se van a encontrar y
no se van a apoyar no porque el amor es
infinito del padre hasta los discos
adicionalmente programe tiempo de
calidad con sus nietos
cada 15 días en la noche del abuelo de
la abuela deje los niños pero no se los
deje todos los días cuando usted está
desocupado creyendo que él no tiene más
nada que hacer
está dentro del respeto
quiero dejarlos con una frase que une
las asistentes al taller una vez le dije
a list ya que te llevas y me dijo hay
esperanza
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]